الارجنتين بطل للعالم بعد 36 سنه من
الانتظار من النكاسات من ال يعني الخساء
الخساره وراء الخساره وراء الخساره حتى
كانت خساره 2014 ولكن هذه المره اليوم
للكاس طعم خاص في اخر مونديال ليونيل ميسي
في اخر كاس عالم للاسطوره لافضل لاعب في
التاريخ تعيدها مره اخرى واللي زعلان طلب
من ميسي تحقيق لقب مع بلاده وجاب كوبا
امريكا كوبا امريكا ما بيستاهل لازم تجيب
كاس العالم جاب كاس العالم الانظر الان
ماذا يمكن ان نقول لمن يزال ربما
ليونيل ميسي بهذا اللقب الناس تختلف في
ناس شايف انه ميسي
لا يجب ان نختلف للحظه واحده على حقيقه
ميسي بانه يطلق عليه لقب افضل لاعب
بالتاريخ وهو طبعا افضل لاعب في تاريخ
الارجنتين من ناحيه الالقاب مع الانديه
ومن ناحيه الان عاجل دييغو ارماندو
مارادونا بالالقاب مع المنتخب الارجنتيني
بالذهاب الى المباراه اسكالون اليوم تفوق
طبعا على ديديه شام كان قارئ المباراه
بشكل افضل ولكن فلتت من الامور ببعض
اللحظات كلفوا هذا الامر الذهاب الى اشواط
اضافيه وبعد ذلك الى ركلات ترجيح المنتخب
الارجنتيني مشكلته هي بعد نفسها نفس
المشكله اللي من بدايه البطوله لحد الان
لما يتلقى هدف بينهار وهو ما حدث تلقى
الهدف الاول من ركله جزاء سبب فيها اوتندي
وبعد ذلك الفريق انهار وتلقى الهدف الثاني
في اقل من دقيقتين عن طريق كيليان مبابي
لذلك هذا الامر اثر وربما عكر صفه همم خطط
اسكالوني اللي كانت ممتازه جدا وانا دخل
باربعه اربعه اثنين بدل ما يعتمد على
الجهه اليمنى متوقعينهم يعتمد على جهد او
الهجوم على جهه كيليان مبابي من الجهه
اليسرى وهاجم عن طريق الخيل دي ماريا اللي
ما حدا كان متوقع ان يلعب اساسي
وكاندي ماريا عم يلعب على عثمان ديمبلي
اللي بدا متوتره من بدايه المباراه اللي
اضاع بعض الكرات في بدايه مباراه بشكل
غريب بسبب التوتر اللي كان فيه وادى ذلك
لانه ارتكب ركله جزاء على ديماريا وتم
اخراجه بعد ذلك سجلت الارجنتين الهدف
الثاني طبعا بكره ممتازه جدا بلعب رائعه
جدا وهو لازم مشيت بدي بول بهذه الكره
اللي كان عم يمنع كل الكرات توصل اللمبات
لانه كان عم يقطع خط التمرير بشكل دائم عن
كيليان مبابي قطع الكره الى زميل الى زميل
الى زميل حتى وصلت الى دماريه اللي سجل
الهدف الثاني للمنتخب الارجنتيني وانتهى
الشوط الاول بثنائيه نظيفه اجبرت على
اجراء تبديلات قبل نهايه الشوط بخروجيرو
وخروج ايضا عثمان ديمبي طبعا
ولكن بعد ذلك امبابه تحول لقلب هجوم
وبعدين رجعوا مره ثانيه لجناح يعني كان في
حاله من التخبط هجوميا بالنسبه للمنتخب
الفرنسي حتى بدايه الشوط الثاني الخطا
اللي ارتكبه سكالوني كان اخراج ديماريا
مبكرا وادخال اكونيا اللي يعني ربما كان
حاس ان مباراه صار لازم تتقفا صار لازم
تتسكر وبالتالي ادخل اكون ليقوم بادوار
دفاعيه ولكن هذا التبديل كلف الارجنتين
كثيره لانه ريح دفاع فرنسا وريح الجبهه
اليمنى عن فرنسا بشكل كامل طبعا ما عم
نحكي انه ازكروني بيتحمل مسؤوليه الهدفين
او هذا التبديل اللي خلف فرنسا ترجع
المباراه تطلع اللي خلف فرنسا ترجع هو
شخصيه الارجنتين ضعيفه ولكن هذا ايضا اثر
على الامر اثر على على سعر المباراه
وفرنسا طبعا رجعت بهدفين وراحت امورنا
الاشواط الاضافيه ميسي لعب دور تشاقه سجل
ثلاثه اثنين طبعا هو اللاعب اللي سجل هدف
الثالث اثنين على المانيا بال 1986 بس
يلعب بنفس الدور وسجل ثلاثه اثنين ولكن
عاد بالنتيجه بركله جزاء اخرى بسبب سذاجه
مدافعين المنتخب الارجنتيني ان كان اكونيا
ولا ان كان اوتندي كلفهم ايضا ركله جزاء
اخرى تصدى لها مبابي وسجلها بالمرمى وراحت
امورنا لركلات ترجيح وبركلات ترجيح ما في
داعي نحكي انه مليان ومارتينز افضل بمراحل
من لوريس ومسك كاس العالم واهداف الاسطوره
ليونيل ميسي لحتى يختم في مسيرته مع
المنتخب ويكون مسك الختام لافضل لاعب في
التاريخ وبما انه لبس البشت فهو شيخ
اللاعبين وافضل من لمس الكره على مر تاريخ
كره القدم على الاطلاق هذه نهايه
التغطياتنا لكاس العالم 2022 من هنا من
قطر نرجو ان نكون قدمنا الاضافه كنا معكم
اول باول 10 لحظات حلوه وعشره لحظات صعبه
ولكن نتمنى بالنهايه نكون وصلنا الصوره
بالشكل المطلوب لا نقول وداعا ولكن الى
اللقاء